the drinks business is big business in  fact the industry is now worth more than  1.4 trillion dollars some of the biggest  sellers may surprise you though these  are the top three according to drinks  international at number 31 you will have  heard of smirnoff the vodkas owned by  beverage giant Diageo and sold almost  234 million litres according to the 2013  report number two a brandy forget  McDowell's and remi martan this one  comes from the philippines it's called  in Parador and sold 279 million litres  but the biggest seller is perhaps one of  the most specific it's called jinro  seeing here performing Gangnam style  it's a brand of soju a Korean drink  traditionally made from rice despite it  being a regional player almost 590  million litres of the stuff was sold two  and a half times the amount of Smirnoff